so I'm fired up because in this deep
dive training we're going to be looking
at some of the biggest mistakes some of
the biggest opportunities and some of
the best ways right now to get views
especially if you're just starting on
YouTube or you have a small Channel but
even if you're more established we're
actually going to be diving into some
actual tactics as we look at some
different YouTube channels around
different topics that a Channel of any
size can learn from so if you're fired
up smash the like button and today I'm
joined by my friend Rob from vid IQ Rob
how's it going hey Sean thanks for
having me on once again on the think
media podcast I'm feeling all of the
Vibes hello to everybody joining us I
just have one thing I need to do since
we are
oh we are live officially live
officially live now yeah so I'm fired up
and we are looking at some channels
today from our video ranking Academy
community and we're starting it off with
flip it furniture and so our goal here
is to learn about the insights the maybe
mistakes points of improvement and
thinking about as you watch this what
could you learn
um from this Channel and what are maybe
even some tips for you to update your
own content right here we've got a
description that is leaving a lot of
details lacking without you know
starting right here
um update your whole Channel meaning
this description at least give me
something here email how if somebody
wants to read out reach out to you you
have 62 000 subscribers what if people
want to do brand deals what if companies
want to reach out to you YouTube gives
you a place to connect an email address
so that Brands could easily reach out to
you or anybody that wants to collab or
Biz Dev hint do not use the email
address that you use to log into your
YouTube channel because you don't want
to give that out there to hackers and so
if you go to for example
um our page here on the think media
podcast Channel we've got a description
a few calls to action no email and I'm
not even sharing my screen but uh no no
email you can't reach us but I want to
say that I think you can on think media
and so this is what YouTube is changing
we can learn uh take a little bit of our
own medicine but we do have two channels
so we've got a descript action on big
media view for business inquiries view
email address again do not use the email
address that you use to log into your
account we actually got hacked on our
think media podcast account I would
argue the account you use
to to log into YouTube should be used
for basically nothing else
um and then you can link up your links
it could be any kind of product Services
you have any social media accounts this
again is not going to be a key to
Growing your channel however
um this is definitely something that'd
be worth updating with 4.7 million views
on the channel Rob 62 000 subscribers
175 uploads
um as we work our way to the main
content I would love to see some more
Community tab posts but I am grateful
that you are doing some surveys that's
good I would love to see you use Square
images and a YouTube link to promote a
video and not just a video you'll get
more reach there and I um would
love to uh see more Community tab action
um you did start a podcast and it's
labeled as a podcast and if y'all did
not know there's now a podcast
tab there's so many things on YouTube
now there's videos there's shorts
there's been zero live streams on this
channel if there was live streams there
would be a live streams Tab and now
there's a podcast Tab and that is if you
classify a playlist as a podcast and do
a few other things it becomes a podcast
and it is official in the US that
YouTube music now is a place where you
can consume podcasts so that's a whole
other thing but that brings us to the
the core stuff we got our cover image we
got our Avatar we've got our thumbnails
we've got our titles and in just a
second we'll preview the video but Rob
I'm curious what is your thoughts on
this channel
first of all I love the channel name uh
flip it uh Furniture to me that
communicates so much
I would love to see a little more
description in the about section as
we've already established and what I
think of when I hear the term flip it in
in terms of furniture is that you're
gonna buy something cheap you're gonna
pimp it out and then you're gonna
potentially sell it for a profit
so is there a way to maybe emphasize
that a little bit more in the thumbnails
more than just Furniture makeover which
is what they tend to be using in the uh
thumbnails right now I'm thinking could
there be a almost like a Stakes added to
this like you bought it for 20 books but
you were able to flip it for a profit of
like 600 books or however much you sold
it again uh Sean because we're lacking a
little bit of detail on the description
and on the thumbnails I'm not exactly
sure what I'm getting into but the
channel name is such a great start for
the channel and you've just now moved
over to the um most popular ones I think
the thumbnails themselves the the detail
of the furniture is high class and it
has a certain style which I think
relates well to this audience but again
just with that bog Standard Furniture
makeover
text on the thumbnails maybe there's a
there's a better way to sell the videos
a bit more so that they have more um I
guess
regular Cadence because we're seeing
these um viral videos that have half a
million views but then I as I was
looking through the rest of their
content I think they're they're staple
view count was between like four and six
thousand views which is good but I feel
as if there's room for more um reach
with a wider audience
yeah and one of the things I want to
shout out here is you know I can spy on
somebody else's Channel using vidiq by
the way today's video is brought to you
by vidiq and a little bit more on that
later but
um using the tools here we can look at
the stats 84 000 views a month 600 new
subscribers
it says one upload but there is four
bumps and let's see if we are doing
shorts the last short was uploaded
[Music]
you got to protect your copyright on
this copyright claims on the stream Sean
um April 10th so active in about a month
ago on a short and then the last upload
was also
um six days ago 13 days ago so it looks
about one a week but one of my favorite
tabs is the trending tab that vid IQ
gives you and you could also see this in
your real-time analytics and this is the
dream of our video ranking Academy a
two-year-old video that's getting 18.5
dph and vph stands for views per hour
and so you get one video you make years
ago and it's still driving views and
bringing you subscribers and so that
would be probably heavily search based
I'm guessing although
being recommended via suggested videos
um and around maybe a certain topic so
all of that's great let's check out a
little preview of a video
I've got my husband helping me out with
some prep work today so he's going to
take out all the drawers and mark them
one two three four so we don't get them
mixed up then he's going to remove all
the hardware so I can clean it up
we flip the piece upside down take our
vacuum and make sure that there's no
dust or debris or any webs or anything
like that we also do the insides of the
drawer Cubbies just to make sure
everything's nice and clean then we use
our White Lightning cleaner which I
already have I love the kind of DSLR
you're using
um good video nice room light uh the
voiceover meets music that's mixed well
meets
um
a little bit of music
storytelling and kind of cutting in the
story is all a very great vibe
and I'm blending I wait 24 hours in
between my coats just to make sure that
I'm not reactivating the first coat
stunning Furniture makeover reactivate
with water blending and para clay paint
so it's a good video and your ability
clearly at 62 000 subscribers your
ability to create great content is clear
I think an opportunity that you have
there though
is
in choosing your topics
um sometimes your view count might be a
little bit lower just because how broad
a pure how interested are people in to a
particular painting style or the way
your furniture makeover is positioned
and for your subscribers I feel like
that's kind of what this energy gives me
like the people who love you the people
who have been helping me out with
something they cut right into the story
um and what I might suggest is if we go
seems like that's that's been a certain
I I what what's interesting is yeah I
wonder if you used a little bit of how
to and if anybody who knows me they know
I love starting a video with how to and
this isn't to say even in replacing any
content you're doing it's saying in
addition to thinking about like these
practical videos there's another one
with the four views per hour two years
old just because it's how to remove
bubbles from laminate Furniture it's the
type of content that will continue to be
viewed and like how to solve a specific
problem even within the video itself as
a side note I always like to think about
working smarter and I not harder and not
with some prep work perhaps one of the
ways to do that is if you're gonna film
this video anyways it's a whole makeover
is there a video inside of this video
that actually might end up getting more
views in the video itself like quick
tips for sanding down such like how to
sand down antique furniture or something
and during the time which I would
imagine you were filming this video in
uh one setting uh or all the clips and
then you went back and narrated it later
so if you had all the clips anyways you
might say
are you curious about how to so even
with the footage on your hard drive
there could be videos positioned around
like one question one answer which could
be a way to leverage the content that
you have even more
um but anything else as we land the
plane Rob
I think the Creator does a fantastic job
of creating a video that's a high
production value like you can see the
spending a lot of time with the edit and
the voiceover throughout absolutely
critical so that's brilliant fantastic
the one thing I noticed in this
particular video that we're watching
Sean um was that
um it wasn't this one I think there's
one before but
I liked how the Creator jumped straight
into the video but at the same time you
mentioned something which I thought was
interesting that it would be really good
video for subscribers and people who are
familiar with their contents but how
accessible is it for somebody who's
accounts encountering your content for
the first time because it kind of just
drops us in there without maybe
explaining why uh they were why your
husband was there working on this
furniture because the essence of your
channel as far as I'm aware from your
channel name is Flip It Furniture so I
think a little bit more of an
introduction of what you were working on
why you were working on it uh how this
may help a viewer watching the content
you know and again going back to that
idea of buy cheap flip it into something
that's more valuable I miss that I guess
value proposition but it was just that
one video Sean so I don't know if that's
uh the same way they introduce all of
their videos
yeah I feel the same way regarding the
hook uh that potentially could uh have
happened there and you know one thing I
one final thing again how can we apply
this to everybody watching all the way
back on that first video chalk paint
furniture
um I do think there could be some you
know powering up of the title powering
up of the positioning yeah and then and
then powering up of the hook
um and so
one of my favorite tools is uh the vidi
vid IQ AI title recommendation tool nice
I'm just going to type in chalk paint
furniture here and look at maybe some of
the um title recommendations can't
believe what this furniture looks like
off after a chalk paint makeover
watch how she transforms old furniture
with chalk paint in just five minutes
what I also love about if you do this
ideation using a tool like this before
you press record or actually it's not
necessarily a problem because if you
just got the the B rule before you
record the voiceover perhaps because if
you know this you're like and it maybe
didn't take you five minutes to do it
but you start thinking about you know
you could see how to transform it in
just five minutes these things could
could uh could be helpful and so it's
really wouldn't you say Rob it's not
even just title recommendations it's
really angle recommendations it's it's
almost idea recommendations true it's
injecting curiosity and Intrigue and
then in those particular titles it was
almost like a fear of missing out you
know if you do not watch this video then
you're not gonna see how we can
transform terrible Furniture into
something that's amazing and looks
genuine and authentic and as if you just
got into a really expensive store and
bought it it kind of crunches up all of
those ideas in in your head from a title
that's about 50 to 70 characters long so
I love those I love those
recommendations they're so close on what
I was suggesting like what video inside
of the video you already made could you
make transform old furniture with this
chalk paint trick so at some point in
there you did the chalk paint my thought
is this is a 15 minute video it's story
based I I did actually find my way all
the way over to the older one
um that's 660 000 views so this one is
crushing but is there one trick is there
one thing you know that's like hey to
get chalk paint to look a certain way or
whatever and and then
um footage that's already on your hard
drive fresh you know voice over you show
them the trick and or you just narrate
it too you could always just sit down
and be like hey you know recently we
worked on a project you're on camera and
then you cut to the voiceover you know
how to create content so you can figure
that out but again I love this idea of
if you're doing the takeaway is if
you're doing something
longer here'd be my example I do a lot
of like death setups because Tech you
know microphones cameras you might know
myself and Omar Nolan over on think
media for that
so if I'm going to do an entire desk
setup I always think okay the entire
desk setup is a video it's 10 or 15
minutes and there's like 26 things in
there the studio monitors the monitors
the camera the tripod the microphone the
lighting but then
I'm like well there's probably five of
those things that are super interesting
like what is the best budget USB mic for
2023 that's one piece of the whole tour
and I might think like
DIY headphone hanger because I found a
particular way to create a headphone
hanger and so what video inside of the
videos you're already making could help
you get more uploads hit more angles and
at times the death tour the desk setup
right might get 10 000 views 20 000
views let's say but the the headphone
hanger might get a quarter million and
so when you have more at bats you have
more opportunities to get views Reach
people answer specific questions so
anyways if you want to check out that AI
title recommendations tool and even get
a 30-day trial of bit iq's paid plan uh
for just a dollar you could go to
vidiq.com forward slash think or you
could also go to the comments depending
on where you're watching this and
Victoria will drop that link for you
um or check out the YouTube description
and that is one of our favorite tools so
check it out and next up is Beach Bum
and Dad smash like if you're learning
some things getting some ideas for your
own channel life is hard
but at the beach all stress
washes away
this is a beachy Channel where I explore
beautiful beaches and gather amazing
sea shells we do have a business
inquiries email address we do have
Facebook and Instagram
we have
seashell pictures on the community tab
right on nice pitches yeah these are
beautiful and it definitely is on brand
for
the subscribers I mean even the
engagement there someone is definitely
clicking subscribe for the beauty
they're clicking subscribe for the beach
we do have our store with spread shop
integrated so that's cool to have this
is great stuff too shells are precious
I like selling shelling and maybe three
people is that too many so a bunch of
kind of
interesting uh merch products print on
demand that's nice couple live streams
and then we find our way over to let's
see what's happening with shorts
hustle when Wednesday wisdom Hustle uh
we'll come back to that I wonder if Rob
has opinions about this but my question
for the moment is just
when did this come out and this came out
today so and Abraham Lincoln quote over
some shells interesting and then we've
got our main videos here with two years
ago
uh maybe a vlog of some kind with 24 000
views shelling 101 a little more
tutorial based whereas lately
we're doing a little bit of a vlog maybe
giving you a location and have you found
any sand dollars
Pensacola Beach shelling in Paradise all
right Rob what are your thoughts
so uh just remind me of the subscriber
size here uh 4000 800 yeah almost five
thousand eight hundred videos so they've
been at this
and committed to it for a while at this
point and each view is consistently
getting around about 500 views maybe a
little bit more maybe a little less well
cool nice run picture to kick us off for
this video a very nice
um I guess my question is from a broader
perspective
um
I need to see more of the titles and
thumbnails but it felt like it was a um
finding shells at the beach Channel
which is something I've never come
across in the thousands of channels that
I've audited uh
up to date so it's a completely unique
uh part of YouTube and there are
audiences for everything on YouTube but
what is the ceiling for this audience
and given that they've done 800 videos
now and you know how long have they been
on YouTube probably several years are
they ever going to have any um breakout
content with this
really specific type of content and if
the answer is probably not then how do
we make this Sean how do we make this
content more accessible to a broad
audience how can we find something
that's really exciting and interesting
that's going to appeal to a huge
audience as opposed to those who are
maybe just interested in shells at the
beach
yeah I also looked up
um
I looked up shelling
on is that it is that what the genre is
uh well I'm actually this is a great
conversation for everybody watching to
think about your branding your messaging
your positioning
because shelling heavy uh by Google's
definition is heavy fire of artillery to
artillery to saturate an area and hit a
specific
um
uh Target so what is shelling by the
ocean uh C shelling is cool so shells
from the ocean what is shelling that is
also
uh in Southwest Florida shelling is the
act of combining Seashore and Beach
looking for the perfect seashells
so
you're exactly right getting clear on
your language we would call it in
business The Tam too the total
addressable Market all of that's
thoughtful when when that's the case
though I think what's what becomes
interesting is I think you got to lean
into like you lean into storytelling you
lean into character development if it
really is going to scale you lean into
that
it's kind of the idea if you think about
a reality TV show where you you take
something that
maybe people thought they wouldn't be
interested in it because it's not
something they do themselves but the
reason they watch is because of the
narrative or the storytelling or
whatever else
um because it definitely is a niche
hobby I also like to ask the question
going deeper Rob on what you're exactly
saying what is the business model and is
is there even like things to
to be able to be
to sell to seashellers like there's
stuff to sell to content creators
affiliate marketing they want to buy
cameras there's stuff to sell to
athletes I just bought a bunch of home
gym stuff and I was educated by a home
gym YouTube channel reviewed
40 24 of the different dumbbells
adjustable dumbbells that was the
individual whose affiliate link that I
ultimately ended up using because of the
education there now that's not the only
business model but if we're thinking
about some of those aspects definitely
thinking about how could you scale and
make this perhaps more broad appeal
or the people who are subscribed here
what else would they be interested in if
it is
because actually I think if we go back
shelling isn't is is the niche within
the niche ultimately it would seem to me
I mean I guess it's virtual shelling but
it's also just beachy adventures and I
think you start going Beach you go
travel you go travel vlogger you go
beaches you go education about areas
that it's I think that's more of a kind
of a proven accepted there's ways to do
that uh we might have been a little bit
focused on the shelling here but any Rob
thoughts about how you could broaden
this up or maybe
um scale the channel more I think you're
exactly right Sean with the storytelling
aspect of it how to weave in interesting
and intriguing curious stories
within your umbrella of shelling I did
actually do a search for shelling on
YouTube and it does come up with all of
these seashell exploration uh channels
um but what is a little concerning here
is if you look at the top results you
know thousand views 19 hours ago
37 000 views two months ago three
thousand views usually for a search
topic to be really interesting you want
to be seeing videos at the top of a list
with you know hundreds of thousands tens
of thousands of views
um for it to have a broad audience so I
think yeah Sean maybe they do have to
explore a little bit beyond their
um topic having said that I found s WF
Beach life they have 50 000 subscribers
and their videos are getting 10 000
views per video if not more so that's
certainly a um
how do I what do I call this like a a
passive collaboration where you can
maybe watch some of their videos and see
how they're talking about the
conversation of shelling and how can
they add to it if they want to stay
niched into their topic
yep and then the final thing I would say
is
kind of talking back to business model
because especially too if you follow
think media podcast and you think and
you're part of era you know that we're
we're asking about the practicality of
of reverse engineering how could this be
a full-time job and I'm not sure what
your current you know multiple flows of
income or whatever what day job versus
retired or versus uh different things
but I know you already have the merch
thing going but I did look up like
selling T-shirts and it for sure is a a
legit subculture right and so I do think
that
no pun intended your goal is to be a big
fish in a small ocean and uh the goal
would be to to think about perhaps
you know recently we had chalene Johnson
on our podcast and I was talking about a
thousand true fans concept and she was
like I don't even think it's a thousand
I think it's like 500 true fans you
really build like a Die Hard community
and there is maybe a channel memberships
aspect or people buying your merch
aspect
um and so then it becomes a matter of
um I'm not sure if your mark if you just
set up the store and upload the things
and you hope that people discover these
um but hope is not a strategy I think
there's something about I'm not sure
maybe merch is going good for you but
maybe the way you build your merch and
and saying that let's actually look at a
video you know if I watch a channel like
Phil DeFranco he's talking about his
merch all the time but he's not it's but
it's not pushy or because he has so much
value so it's like it's if you weave it
into the content then I think it becomes
interesting and so we did watch some of
that Drone footage but let's check this
out
okay so I'm going to grab a jacket and
some shoes get some keys and coffee oh
boy I almost forgot the backpack
how many baggies do we need today
well
looks like I can find at least one sand
dollar let's take a couple bags all
right here we are I think I have
everything there have been days where I
forgot this might not be our best
example but I am not into this intro for
a couple reasons
one I'm not sure what's happening with
the video and maybe it's just your
smartphone or whatever but it is way too
cropped in already like the low light
morning shot of the shoes is
not even my favorite shot but especially
it feels like it's 5xed on digital is
Imaging digital Zoom
um and and thinking about that that hook
now it is I get the quick Vlog edits I
see a little spot up here hopefully
already this is a better shot and more
uh visible and and it could also back to
that you could you could hook it with
different visuals or something different
up front and then eventually get to the
storytelling this one feels it's very
vloggy so I respect the video in its own
merits for that regard because it
literally is
exactly what you sort of promised there
you're you're sort of like I'm gonna go
Vlog it's it was the whole day in a
linear fashion but then the thing to
reverse engineer backwards would be
which type of videos perhaps maybe do a
little bit better I wonder why this one
did better
[Music]
and here's my exact point you clearly
can put out an intro that comes with a
whole nother level of energy a whole
nother level of a hook a whole nother
level of the opening shot being really
strong
coming up
and I mean if there's my desire like
you're you're wetting my appetite for uh
attractive shells
[Music]
final thoughts Rob
there were some good aspects of this
intro but this is dragging on a little
bit I mean it had this nice musical
montage and now we've had to wait
another 20 seconds of like
title credits swinging it's not moving
we don't need to know who produced it
and uh and that type of thing let's just
jump into it I also thought that
um for that intro there were static
images
I think it just needed one or two
moments of b-roll motion and maybe one
reaction from the Creator themselves
like to really hype it up like the
what's its shelling on Panama City Beach
it might have been something along the
lines of I couldn't be shelling anywhere
else better in a world like that could
have been like the the moment to capture
that that hook
um but yeah credit to um him to for
trying these a vlogging storytelling
videos especially when a lot of them are
15 to 20 minutes
given that intro that we saw I think
there is likely opportunities to trim
down the Vlogs a bit more so it has more
pace and uh it's a little tighter story
and so you could maybe try and do you
know you could aim for your next Vlog to
be however long it usually would be
let's say 16 minutes challenge yourself
to make it an eight minute Vlog and just
see how that impacts the the pace and
the storytelling of the video and as we
land the plane on this channel before
our next one hit like if you're getting
some insights using the AI title
recommendations from vid IQ I typed in
shelling in Florida and this first one I
mean it just leaps off the page so if
you start with Concepts like this and
kind of ties back into what I was trying
to communicate with storytelling
uncovering the mystery of shelling in
Florida you won't believe what we found
so that feels to me kind of like a
little mini reality show and the way the
video then becomes structured would be
how it's structured is storytelling
based hooking the viewer's attention
there is conflict and tension created at
the beginning
um and then there's you know ultimately
resolution in regards to what you ended
up finding it's interesting discovering
the secrets there also could be very
much practical based videos five best
places to go shelling in Florida
three one must see Beach the best Beach
unbelievable footage in Florida if you
have some of the unbelievable footage
that also could be like a long long long
form video with nice music
can maybe a collaboration a compilation
of a lot of the different footage you
found
um and uh that IQ definitely helping us
crank up that value like shelling in
Florida what we found will shock you
um unbelievable selling in Florida will
leave you speechless
I found shelling gold in Florida and
then I would also perhaps you could go
deeper and deeper deeper into shelling
but as you rise up a little bit more
into Beach bumming the opportunity there
seems extensive and so thanks for being
a part of the VRA Community thanks for
um
uh great job in the consistency and I
hope some of that stuff was helpful
which next up we have
Niraj
mathrani
and he's doing a Career Success coach
leadership productivity personal
development new content every week
um we are at 258 subscribers 55 videos
16 000 views
he's built out the about page rather
you're facing a rough situation at work
how to get more out of your current job
or looking for a better one I'm here to
support you so it's really
career Career Success coach so I get it
okay so like you you have a job get
promotions become a leader
he's been in leadership roles he's got
his business uh address he does have a
buy me a coffee which is a kind of
another way that you can get tips from
people
not so much even like patreon or
anything like that it's just a way for
someone to give you one three or five
five coffees okay so coffee is five
dollars so one coffee is five dollars
where do you buy your coffee
that's cheap Michael
coffee's like fifteen dollars shorts
would be
coming out here and we've got our
biggest one when your boss asks you dot
dot we've got 1200 views on a short
let's see the energy we got the little
wireless microphone here why this
question can make people nervous or
anxious because they don't have yes I
cannot adjust the volume of a short but
this seems really quiet to me
I don't know if it's quiet to you Rob I
want to say it's Max
or maybe does it match the volume to
what you said it on a long form video
how long does it last yeah yeah I'm not
sure looking over yourself there's Max
there so I'm now I'm maxed and I'm
refreshing and I'm all there and now
let's see
I didn't know that until we just tested
it
people nervous or anxious because they
don't have the answer on the spot which
I actually wish you could control over
here yeah confident and competent by
giving an estimated date to the estimate
tip for everybody watching I would say
is uh that you can learn from this
channel is the
um audio quality and the lighting
quality is all great and those things
they they matter especially in a channel
like this you know production value
a lot of times should be reverse
engineered on what is your promise like
what's the expectation it's maybe the
expectation that you have a GoPro if
you're doing extreme sports it's maybe
the expectation that if you're doing
like a tutorial on Zoom it's probably
not going to be very good quality but in
this case this your teaching
professionals
I like that you're coming across as a
professional good lighting good audio
good communicator
I like that okay over to the videos
looks like we are doing kind of a video
podcast style we certainly are because
there's three episodes in leadership
uh
podcast that maybe just recently started
and what are your thoughts Rob I just
wanted to mention as well in terms of
the production quality on the show uh
did you notice that he was wearing
different outfits in the same show and I
know from experience that that can take
a long time to do to think about these
different characters and then to get
changed and then you realize that you
the one part of the filming went wrong
so you have to change back into the
outfit and record it that that is
appreciated
um effort and quality from a from a
fellow creator
I think Sean the general value
proposition here is a little too weak
and generic when we go to a channel
banner and we see what are essentially
keywords leadership productivity
personal development
well I think everybody who's a a
personal coach a career coach could just
plonk those words in a channel Banner
how can uh Niraj stand out what's their
unique
value proposition as this person and how
can you emotionally trigger a desire in
myself
to watch content from you how successful
am I going to get what what can I earn
like where do I see myself in the next
two years all of these questions you can
answer as you build up an ideal Avatar
or viewer and then inject That Into You
said this before Sean like you're North
Star or your Creed so just from that
perspective I think there's more that
can be done on a branding
in terms of the thumbnails what I'm
seeing is a little bit of I'm going to
start from scratch with every single
thumbnail that I make and so they all
look significantly different so again we
lose some of that branding consistency
uh that is there as well uh these are
the most popular videos right that
you've sorted by at the top so we
haven't had any real big breakout videos
just yet but they tend to be listical
how to's
um which is fine uh what I would say is
that uh you're covering a topic that's
been covered on YouTube for the last 15
years or existence of YouTube uh I am
starting to recommend that a secret
power
in YouTube
right now is short searching serve up
fast 10 times we are looking at all of
the big Search terms in YouTube
education and we are remaking those
Search terms as shorts not only because
we're seeing our shorts search traffic
increase significantly but
when you do a Google search those shorts
are now appearing on Google pages and
when you think about you know a
googler's intent you know I'm searching
for an answer and I want a quick answer
to it if I see a 40 second answer in a
YouTube shop versus a 40 minute video
I'm probably going to click on the shot
so think about converting those
long-form search based videos into
shorts as well
I also
um think that topic opportunities for
you because some of the things
once you've developed a core set of
skills so I think that there's something
about you know everybody watching this
whether you're new here or whether
you've been rolling with us for a while
and think media podcast VRA
I think that you know communicating
audio lighting editing you have the
ability to make some great videos yeah
so now we think topic we could uh topic
becomes a big opportunity and I think
one of your topics that could be
interesting is really
getting to know your viewer
um let's go practical today you could
take an action and everybody watching
this can take an action to perhaps do it
exactly what you did here if I could
change one thing about what's your
current job higher position more
opportunities to learn better manager
higher salary I'm guessing it's higher
salary what would you pick Rob
foreign
I would want is missing it's like a
happiness
more happiness yeah I've just been
content because through your job or like
would you call that more time off or
more freedom no I think it's through my
job because I always say that the moment
I started working for vid IQ I've not
worked today in my life because it feels
like I'm getting paid to do the thing
that I love
so let me ask you too if you could
change one thing about your current job
and you're watching this drop it in the
comments I'll pull some up in just a
second I'm guessing that everybody says
hi or so there's four votes it's a
hundred percent so I mean it was like I
was I don't even know if that was my
answer I'm just saying I'm guessing I'm
like yeah you're gonna go with higher
salary it also is first and that could
be like quiz Theory or like survey
Theory
um but you know I realize you're you
don't have a ton of subscribers so
anybody watching this that does this you
know building up your community to have
culture does take some time but
nevertheless you did get four votes
counting mine and you get a little bit
of insight about where you could go next
when you don't have a lot of audience
feedback you have to just dive deep into
the psychology of your target audience
and here's what I would ultimately say
and I would ultimately mean
um if you really want to help these
individuals you're asking what are the
top 10 to 20 Questions they're they're
asking and I'm sure
like
promotion let's say if you have stuff on
promotion how to get a promotion okay
great
um how about how about
a higher salary let's type in salary
you want to increase your salary good
um but now okay even that you've made a
lot of videos over the last couple five
months
the core biggest desire though of the
macro amount of people is probably
higher salary without getting the
philosophy
so you should probably make 30 videos
about how to increase your salary but
then let's go a little bit deeper and
now we're back to the vid IQ title
recommendations how to get a raise my
secret strategy is revealed okay make
that one unbelievable tips on how to
Triple your salary make that one as well
now of course we're not about hype here
you're actually fine you find a case
study you do the research you find
someone who actually did triple their
strategy you reverse engineer the seven
things they did to do it and you turn
that into a video or you've done it at
some point or you did it over time
you're like I started at my job at 42
000 a year eventually I work my way up
want big money these salary secrets to
change your life discover how to make a
six figure salary this is kind of like
we've learned that we make best camera
under 500 best camera under a thousand
dollars best camera under uh
five thousand dollars
like
how to how to discover the best ways to
make you know a hundred thousand dollars
a year discover the jobs that pay 250
000 a year discover how you know
easy ways to ask your boss for a
promotion to get five to ten thousand
dollars more per year and so all that to
say is like even when it feels crowded
it's not crowded you just need these
skill sets and you've got you need the
content creation skill set which is
there but then sometimes the positioning
the topics
um and I also then think it would be
interesting where I'd call this trend
surfing
where you are a a distributor of data
like meaning what are Trend five Trends
in
hiring firing layoffs is a recession
coming how to protect yourself from
layoffs like there's so much that is
that could happen within this but what
it all comes back to is the creator who
understands the viewer best wins anyway
what that means is what is keeping them
up at night what are they stressed about
and what are the other four areas like
you know how to ask your boss for more
time off how to create more freedom uh
and wellness in the workplace but
perhaps those topics might not have as
much reach but you think through what is
keeping my ideal viewer up at night what
is their core desires what are their
problems and Ambitions those types of
things I think on the other side of the
great content you're creating there's a
lot of opportunity when you really dial
in your topics smash like if you've been
learning something today and we're going
to learn really quick here from some of
the people here live
for square table degenerates they said
for me
it's only higher salary
I mean it's like and it's one of these
uh they're not surprising I mean
especially too inflation like cost of
living like even just they say money
doesn't buy happiness but I figure if
you have enough money or they say money
is not the key to happiness but I figure
if you have enough money you could have
a key made
um that's a stupid dad joke but uh
ultimately uh but like the the funny
thing is obviously no money itself you
could have a lot of money to be
miserable but sometimes that threshold
so I would definitely go back when you
can attach your channel and and just
quick little rant here you know the best
online marketing
topics and niches on a macro level are
Health relationships and money
proven as far as especially even cpms
even like whatever why because there's
there's products in Commerce supporting
them what does that mean relationships
people want to get married figure out
how to recover after divorce figure out
their dating life figure out their
single life figure out their
mother-in-law how to deal with her
figure out how to deal with inline
relationships is what we all experience
um experience more love strengthen their
marriage uh money how do I make money
how do I save money how do I invest
money for retirement how do I get into
crypto how do I anything related to
finance personal finance but money how
do I get out of debt should I use credit
cards and of course that long tails all
the way down to Reese uh you know uh
realist state it yeah all the way down
into niches within how to make money
jobs careers
um and then
you know relationships money and then
Health how do I live longer how do I
anti-aging how do I feel more energy how
do I you know so there's Fitness and
there can be anything from biohacking to
vitamins to doctors to Medical
but here's the big unlock is you might
go well my Niche is not in that what you
need to do is attach your messaging and
the value proposition of your content to
those areas because what we're
discovering in those areas is that those
are all human needs so hey you know the
reason I created this Beach Bum in
Channel
is because there's a mental health
crisis in the world we all need more
peace of mind we need more significance
or peace in in a place to escape that's
that's a thought then we also say that
that one's a little challenging you take
one like this then it is do you want to
experience more peace at home and have
better relationships because your career
is not stressing you out uh do you want
to make more money in your career do you
want to learn how to optimize your
career
401ks how to set up your 401k there's
like a million the long tails that all
you know how to set yourself a better
retirement in your career how to set up
your own retirement plan when your
company doesn't have one like the pain
points money related and then
relationships relationships with
co-workers relationships with your boss
whatever so if you actually plant your
topic in either Health money or
relationships
then you're in a really good Niche and
it's very proven historically
if though you're not directly there if
you can figure out we'd also call this
value extension or Benefit extension
where the benefit is on this channel I'm
going to teach you how to make money
the further benefit is you can have less
stress because money problems are one of
the leading causes of divorce your
relationships are going to be better the
benefit is don't you want enough money
so that you can invest in the right
health care or healthy food so you have
more energy so you start thinking about
how you can rap into all of those things
that was quite the uh uh
you know Rabbit Trail but that all came
all the way back to thinking higher
salary right here Peace of Mind Iceland
Adventures uh mentioned peace of mind
and future Revenue
and did anybody else respond to the
question of the day which is
what do you want most from your job
Rob any final thoughts on I think I just
did I do I do actually
um and
it's kind of been an unlock for me in
the last year uh what you've been
describing is how to unlock
browse traffic source for your channel
and what I mean by that if I was to ask
you Sean
what typically is the basic desire for
any YouTuber for their Channel
the very basic desire what do you think
it is
I mean success if that's not too generic
of course but how how do you get success
on YouTube what was the lowest common
denominator probably lowest common
denominator would be views exactly okay
what is the title of this live stream as
an example right
I've been experimenting over the last
couple of last year of saying you know
what in this video the actual content of
the video is going to be about how to
write a good title for your video but
the truth is
a YouTuber
in the mindset of learning how to grow
their Channel isn't really thinking
about what they need which is to write a
good title or to have a good hook or to
make better thumbnails these are all uh
sub headings of the basic desire
so what I've been experimenting with in
recent videos and
um
just generally on the channel is instead
of trying to get to the top of the
search rankings
what we want you to do is see our video
on the home page and you know when
you're on a home page you haven't really
decided what you're going to watch but
if you're seeing your basic human desire
on the home page for the things that
you're interested in I.E you want to
grow your YouTube channel and you see a
video that says small channels oh yes
this is talking to me do this
whatever this is I'm going to hold that
back and tell you what that actually is
in the video
to double your views or to double your
subscribers you know it's a very basic
title but it's all about the emotional
trigger
then you reinforce that in a hook that
you know if your watch is thanks for
watching this video did you know you're
gonna double your views it only takes
five minutes and you're gonna do it by
writing better titles with this formula
I'm going to show you so like within 10
seconds you know how you're actually
giving them what they need you know in
in the thumbnail on a Titleist this is
what you want we know what you want
because we're the same we have these
same desires but we're just one step
ahead of you as the content creator
because we know how to get you there
with this tactic whether it is better
thumbnails better titles etc etc and
through that our browse traffic is now I
think it's double what our search
traffic is and that was the reverse and
this time last year we were doing I
think 1.7 million views a month and now
we're doing three and a half million
views a month and it's because of that
mindset we've managed to now
have people discoverers through search
which is fantastic but the next time
they're on YouTube and they see one of
our thumbnails on the home page and that
really has the emotional trigger to
click that's when there's a real unlock
for creators like we're seeing here
who's been like really specific about uh
the three things to write a star
performance review you know how could
you reword that to say how to earn how
to earn more money from your next
performance review you know like that
re-angling of it so that's my piece on
this
fantastic Zaya and I guess the last
thing is you start to worry well is this
click bait uh I I you know you just
leading me into a video the way to
answer that is if people are watching
and they're commenting positively and
you've got to Highlights the dislike
ratio and YouTube is continuing to
um share your content with more people
then it's not clickbait for your target
audience no matter what the uh minority
naysayers may think
you know and this is a good conversation
because we're you know open for
conversation
The Farley Berg zone is actually saying
what you're talking about is
manipulation and you're trying to
manipulate someone to do something that
would be the most
um
pessimistic way of viewing that it also
could be an appeal to motive fallacy
because manipulation would be uh
appealing to someone's motive and the
other way you could call that is
persuasion though you could call it
influence and the question is influence
can be used for positive or for negative
if you're trying to trick somebody
and get something from them
for selfish reasons yep and do people on
YouTube do that yeah they do
um but at the on the flip side
um what Rob is describing and we're
describing is we're also talking about
marketing and I know marketing you get a
bad rap we're talking about human
psychology but we're also talking about
a lot of people don't know what they
don't know so what they know they want
to do is they want to get a higher
salary and they want to get a promotion
so when you go too specific yeah they
don't click on it so if you if you're
heart centered Mission driven if you
want to help people
it is also your ethical duty to figure
out how to reach as many people as
possible ethically as Rob said he's like
you know somebody could call it
clickbait well it's only click bait is
if you make a promise but you don't
deliver in the video we made a promise
in this video of how to get more views
with a small Channel and if you apply
everything we've been talking about over
the last 53 minutes and over the next 25
then you are going to get more views
that will be a fact if you upload videos
according to the tactics we are talking
about then so ultimately you know what
this time this title could have been a
lot weaker on this very video in this
live stream if we potentially got too
specific what I think is interesting Rob
is we also could have I like both I
think there's a lot of long tail
opportunity it's not the big growth but
it's being able to get the long tail
opportunity of covering the day someone
wants to how do you fill out a r52 form
for an architectural job of that like
that never be a big viewed video however
you might have the great answer to that
so YouTube isn't it that's very VRA to
your point
and all the way back to this channel
when we understand the viewer and when
we understand you know who they are what
they want and what I'm also suggesting
is when you understand just human
psychology a good book on this is
building a story brand what people don't
you you can take the super deep what do
people mostly want on on YouTube you ask
and I was like well it's views
but if you really dig deeper do we even
want views ultimately what's underneath
the surface of that
we maybe want significance
we want a way to express ourselves we
want to be acknowledged as humans why do
we even start YouTube channels we want
to express our creativity we
um we're bullied and we are trying to
prove somebody wrong we're getting super
deep now but it's like why why even
start a YouTube channel or we want leads
and clients and customers for our
business we want a bigger personal brand
why so we can have more money sure so we
can have more impact
so when we think about health
relationships and money another question
came in here about like well where would
time management fall into this
architectural sheet metal asked and uh
time management directly the average
time management we've actually been
looking at the search search term what
is Saving Time fall under
like time management is not a big desire
it's a big desire for a very small
person like it's not sexy it's like
productivity is better we tested these
two things in terms of search volume
there's more like Google Trends like
there's productivity is a Little Bit
Stronger because it maybe it's a little
more positive time Management's like uh
now some of you psychos watching this
myself included you're like no time
Management's like awesome like I buy
books on time management yeah you and
like three percent of the population so
this is also about understanding like
higher level desires of why do we want
to solve time and I think we can tie
this whole thing together with what Rob
is saying is that when it ultimately
comes down to
the reason I want to save time is I want
more time with my kids the reason I want
to save time is I want to
get I want to be I want more money in
less time because I can only work so
much and I don't want to destroy my
health and I want to sleep so if you can
get me more time then I could do another
side hustle or do more of the thing that
generates money or create more I could
write more books or make more videos in
fact you're watching this let me know
why is it that you would want to save
time is it ultimately that you want to
say so you can do more of the things you
love so you have more freedom so by
thinking about the benefit extension and
if you tie that into a title you go core
desire which is like
you know
double your income
colon
five time management strategies
for getting more done in less time
uh or five time management strategies
and and you're attaching the strategy to
the ultimate desire or one of the
desires that people want and if you
study building a story brand this talks
about Marketing in general uh Donald
Miller wrote the book we'll link it up
in the we'll share the link I highly
recommend it for a lot of different
reasons but one of which is again at
people's core is they do want even the
reason to have money is for what money
gets you not for money itself although
maybe some people they could get into
greed or just obsession with money but
money is just a tool that actually
unlocks something else I want to be able
to go eat sushi I want to be able to go
on vacation I want to be comfortable in
retirement I want to be able to not work
all the time so I can have enough money
so I can go visit my family so anyways
let me know if you're getting any aha
moments any unlocks if you have any
questions before question marks before
and after this you never know where
these streams are going to go but we
have taken a turn and Rob I think you
were looking something up what do you
got for us no I was uh for Saving Time
on Google and all of the top searches
are actually about why Daylight Savings
Time exists so
yeah that probably isn't the right
search term for productivity
um yeah and so this is uh been a fun
conversation
and
um
with
that
today's stream we have a couple more
channels for you but today's stream is
brought to you by vid IQ and you're
asking for a good topic research
strategy
there are many and I know that I believe
architectural sheet member metal you're
in VRA so I would encourage you to check
out your modules you could go deep there
but
um to look at another cool tool that's
very practical from vid IQ
under our oh by the way all of this
stuff is at app.vidiq.com so it's the
web-based vid IQ platform
um there is some that's integrated into
the that IQ Vision as well but I love
going here you've got your personalized
ideas now to be clear I'm logged into
think media our other channel and I love
this because I could look at why I
stopped editing on Adobe Premiere
I tried YouTube automation for 60 days
these are recommendations titles but
really topics their video ideas
how I gain 5000 subscribers fast on
YouTube growth tips for small YouTubers
by the way one of the reasons why I love
this too is you might go oh there's so
many videos like that but what's cool
about this is the specific number
like you start realizing that some
people want to hit that a thousand goal
that 5 000 goal okay so those are
personalized but taking it back up here
you can actually get some customized
video ideas by entering a topic and so
before we go to the next Channel I want
to come over here to Career Success and
look at what kind of I want to type in
career development see where that takes
us
where it takes us we don't know and why
that's doing it let me just remind you
that you can get a 30-day trial of it
iq's paid plan for just one dollar at
vidiq.com forward slash think and as we
look at this uh Career Development okay
how to Ace your job interview great nice
how to rank your videos to mix okay how
to Ace your career path five ways to
boost your career confidence
five six mindsets for career development
five creative ways to Market yourself so
in terms of topics this would be one of
many tools we'd recommend whether you
know asking your audience could be a way
community tab could be hey what is your
biggest challenge if you've got people
following you that's always helpful but
what I love about this tool is you can
look into some of these things and you
can even click on it and then it'll pop
up what are Rob is this basically the
ranked kind of videos for this
yeah it's related and best performing
videos based on it's kind of doing a
YouTube search for like so is searching
on YouTube how to AC our job interview
which is great because you can pop it
open and see if there's inspiration on
title and thumbnail right here and see
how to Ace and interview the number one
insanely effective tip and maybe you
what's cool then is you can also combine
these tools so where again we're
applying this to me raja's channel we
could go back to the title
recommendations and say how to Ace an
interview and then go even deeper on
that so as we're building out the topic
we're like okay I'm gonna do some job
interview
uh tips I definitely got those so and
I'm sure you do you probably have three
tips five tips so you could come up with
okay how even how to Ace an interview is
kind of interesting you take that angle
from the vid IQ daily ideas tool
take it over to the AI title
recommendations tool and then pop that
in there and uh while that's working
again if you want to check out any of
that stuff then
um vidiq.com forward slash think is
where you can get a one dollar trial of
the paid plan but also there's a free
version of an IQ that is incredibly
powerful and you can also download vid
IQ vision and plug that into Google
Chrome and that's where you get a lot of
the data and you can see
um according if someone's tagged their
videos if they're ranking and where
things may be ranking there and uh it's
a it's a pretty cool thing thoughts on
using the daily ideas tool Rob
yeah it's been one of our I guess first
Ventures into Ai and it was developed I
think two years ago now and it's just
been slowly improving all of the time
and as you say uh Sean one of the
benefits is that
it takes the work away well all the hard
work away from you if you're a
relatively new to YouTube and let's say
you've uploaded 20 videos but you're
still trying to figure out exactly how
to best
Target your audience it's going to be
bringing up those ideas
um at least I think up to 50 every
single day but now that we've added this
uh new um customization one where you
can say I want to go a little bit off
what it's recommending me to do some
searches as we've just done there with a
single job interview uh yeah really
really powerful stuffer and uh All I'm
gonna say this is a bit of a tease
but next week
we're releasing something that could
change your YouTube life forever
I may be able to tease it to you Sean
after this stream but
All I'm gonna say is
AI
YouTube vid IQ
Next Level next week
I can't wait and uh I will hold you to
that as soon as this stream is over but
we do have a couple more channels
um I will say what I did was I took how
to Ace a job interview over to vidiq's
AI coach and said write 10 titles on how
to Ace a job interview and we've got
interview success Secrets how to impress
and get hired nail your next interview
proven techniques for acing it The
Ultimate Guide to async job interviews
tips and tricks winning interview
strategies how to stand out and get
hired interview confidence so anyways
you can check all of that out that's
another cool way of doing it and with
that we have another Channel
that is Ellen Elizabeth travels
she has
1100 subscribers
61 000 views her channel was created at
the end of 2022. wow fantastic to get a
thousand subscribers in six months and
probably close to four thousand watch
hours if not already hit that
impressive educational videos travel
Vlogs let's get that business email
because who knows what opportunities
will come your way I just had a
conversation earlier today too it was
actually with um Mary's Nest who's one
of our video record Academy students
she's going to hit a million subscribers
and she's in a network of small uh
YouTube creators and different channels
that are in kind of DIY and homesteading
and cooking and all that kind of stuff
and uh great consistency great growth go
for green we always say go for green and
and you've got growth all around
but what she was saying was that small
YouTube channels are getting a lot of
Brando opportunities especially if you
have a clear Niche like this somebody
that wants to get
their you know travel battery they're
solar powered RV battery in front of
people or things like that and um I
think that you just want it to be easy
for people to contact you so putting
together that business email could be
really helpful
um
okay your best performing video is Chris
okay yeah this is Christmas decorations
inside of a RV I do wonder and and
perhaps this was found getting to Look a
Lot live Christmas uh this was perhaps
um
the YouTube shorts I know can because of
click-through rate or because of
whatever else here's what this is
missing just to get a little specific
perhaps a text title and perhaps just a
little bit of a difference in the title
itself at first I thought that this was
like a cabin and it wasn't clear to me
that this was an RV but that's inferred
in your mind because it's a it's a
travel channel but I do wonders like
you know Christmas RV decorations would
already be you know or small RV or
whatever and it it if that could happen
to the search short search but even just
YouTube having enough data but
all that aside
having a headline or whatnot if you
built this out in YouTube shorts itself
using the text tool in YouTube shorts if
at the top during the first five to ten
seconds you let me know what I was
looking at because when I was looking at
the fireplace there
it is not clear to me that that is an RV
um and so if you want to hook the
viewer's attention right at the
beginning they might that is a very
specific space to be decorating
um for Christmas so that's that's kind
of interesting and cool so uh RV tour
solo female traveler living full time in
an RV trailer four months ago 20 minute
video 32 000 views Strong's Earth hi I'm
Ellen welcome to my traveling home AKA
my cat sanctuary AKA my karaoke Hall AKA
my happy place by the way that here's
why this was a great hook uh there's a
lot to reverse engineer here
for the opening shot is a story the
opening shot is a story it is the
characters involved in the story is the
RV the characters involved in the story
is you hi I'm Ellen welcome to my
traveling home you cast The Vision
welcome to my traveling home great
and in a very short time without boring
me as the viewer
that is hooking me into the story you
are sharing
subculture connection points what Pat
Flynn calls super fans connection points
with the viewer whether I'm a cat person
or not it's I'm understanding AKA cat
sanctuary all right okay I like you like
all right we're ready to go a little bit
deeper I'm a cat person too a my karaoke
karaoke AKA karaoke haul a little bit of
Personality oh you're into karaoke
you're into music you're fun AKA
and we're just that was only nine
seconds I said nine seconds and and the
shot is interesting too because even in
nine seconds I'm not maybe even looking
at you I'm like oh cool RV what do we
got going on there okay it's Mount
series all right what's and there's
enough interest happening a lot that was
some Super Fan power right there in nine
seconds and and what some of us I think
make the mistake of doing is we're like
okay yeah I want to build those
connections I want people to know I'm a
track here I want people to know I'm
into Starcraft too I want people to know
I grew up listening to Wu-Tang I want
people to know and so so we think like
so I should probably make like a
documentary about all those things no
you could you could see those touch
points
and even in the you know the opening of
a video or whatnot rather quickly and
for some people they'll just blow right
past them but for others that are like
oh okay you're a cat person too and boom
you have that opportunity to make that
connection
[Music]
time codes chapters grateful
because and this video is also a great
case study because
it is um
got 32 000 views it's a way to come out
the gate really strong 2019 Outdoors RV
Creekside 21 Rd okay Rob what are your
thoughts
so what I noticed if we were going to
start to pick on some areas of
improvement uh just looking at their
videos the thumbnails I thought could do
with a little bit more
um work
what I'm not a fan of is this text
not only because there's too much text
on the thumbnails but the font itself is
quite thin so it makes it difficult to
read and you know Sean as we were
looking at that intro
that was an intro that didn't have any
text on it but you as you say told so
many stories uh without having to have
uh really obvious image imagery on it
and then just thinking about their most
popular video which was uh was it solo
female Traveler
um
how often do they tap into that
target audience when specifically
addressing Their audience in the title
and the thumbnail
um because it's a standout video I think
you had 30 000 views and it's really
speaking to who they want to attract as
that you see that is compared to the the
rest of their videos like 32 000 versus
900 400 400.
how do we as you say Sean success leaves
Clues make a part two of this RV tour
because it's certainly the standout
video for them
yeah I think that's a great Insight I
also do think
there's many different distinctions
about YouTube videos but length
I'm gonna make a statement here in 2023
May 3rd
longer is better
I don't even want to justify it because
there's no books or anything it's just
longer is longer is better
um
what is funny Rob is you make statements
or you make principles and and really a
lot of principles are to be held in
tension well then are you saying don't
make YouTube shorts
did I say that I just said longer is
better are you saying
and I understand that you want the
context but what the reason longer is
better is because at the end of the day
people want
YouTube Wants You on YouTube for as long
as possible so longer is better
YouTube wants people watching your
videos for as long as possible so if you
made a three minute video and you only
had one video on your channel then the
maximum amount of time they could spend
on your channel is three minutes unless
they re-watch the video whereas if you
had a three hour video and they loved it
and they watched the entire thing and
other people also loved it well then
that would be three hours of watch time
so just what I mean by longer is better
is um interestingly enough this is a
similar title solo female traveler
traveler to the famous Janelle Elena's
scenario it kind of TAPS into that and
it's sort of like the story itself even
and I mean she had a snake in the three
cats like success leaves Clues that's a
whole nother level of tapping into uh
that but like you could read you could
update this but what I mean is if you
can here's the takeaway for everybody
watching
if you cannot you're not trying to make
a 20 minute video full of fluff and
nothing of Interest
there is distinct value a whole story
here if you can come up with a 20 minute
and 43 second video that's rich
thoughtful structured edited has a
pretty good average view duration
perhaps the average duration of this
video is six seven eight nine minutes
long which would be wild because the
average
average view duration on YouTube's like
four minutes so even if it's 20 in
average percentage is only 40 but that's
still
eight and a half minutes average
YouTube's Really Gonna like that and
that approves it appears that way
because you got the 32 000 views so when
possible to make high value long content
is all I mean by longer is better and
what is interesting is that the
follow-ups you know are seven eight six
now again there is a lot of other video
videos and I'm not trying to like have
that quote be taken out of context I
like all kinds of video links
um but I do think that's interesting
that the positioning I'd like the
thumbnail I think it is interesting
because it's a kind of a cool photo you
got the cat in there and if we go full
circle the top comment is it pinned it's
not even pinned 46 thumbs up
is
from a woman with three cats
and so this apps back into what one of
the things we're doing on it never
underestimate
YouTube is community YouTube is
relationships and a lot of the nuances
that we relate on family are you a
parent do you have kids do you have cats
are you in an RV and amp were you a
deadhead did you follow the Grateful
Dead did you uh you know are you really
into headphones and audio file stuff are
you into collecting cards are you into
collecting shells we love to Rally
around people with similar values
similar beliefs similar Community
another good book to talk about is
um to recommend is we're all weird
kind of goes back to
um a little bit of the marketing and
positioning stuff we were talking about
earlier but Seth Godin
wrote a book called
we're all weird
the end the myth of mass
what do we always say if you try and
reach everybody you end up reaching
nobody
you don't want to try to reach the
masses it's the rise of tribes in the
end of normal world of warcrafters
larpers settlers Catan weird
Belieber swifties
weirder
um paleos vegans carb loaders pretty
weird Mets fans Yankees fans bears found
fans definitely weird face it we're all
weird so why are companies trying to
build products for the masses why are
YouTube creators still trying to make
videos for the masses
why are we still acting like the masses
even exist where does the new normal and
only YouTube creators that figure this
out have a chance of survival this book
shows you how pretty good just reading
his like thing it's like and you're like
wow did Seth pay you he did actually
this no I'm just kidding Sean you kind
of shot GPT that you said rewrite this
as a YouTuber and just fill that all
over it's real time why yeah why are why
are YouTube creators still acting as if
the masses exist the it's it's niching
down but it's thinking about what are
those rally points of like you know hey
I'm a solo female traveler I'm obsessed
with Taylor Swift I grew up you know
there's a horse I'm pulling behind it
these are just different distinctions or
I'm really into Pokemon so anyways we'll
link that one up as well because I think
that these resources
for some who are like why don't you just
talk about tactics this is the game
tactics actually are like the little
activities you do titles thumbnails
perhaps your description video
optimization even tactics on the hook
but if you don't have your overall
strategy right
if you don't have the bigger strategy
right then tactics are gonna honestly
kind of be a waste of time tactics are
the noise before defeat
something Sun Tzu said something like
that tactics without strategy is the
noise before defeat tactics without
strategy if you follow Rob and by the
way Rob is from vid IQ and and in a
second when we end you can check out his
channel of course and you should you
probably already subscribed
um and you should get all the tactics
like let's figure all the best practices
we have a lot of VRA members here there
is a lot of tactics but tactics without
strategy is the noise before defeat
man if your strategy is not right so
that's another resource that book's
called uh whatever we are all weird the
rise of tribes in the end of normal by
Seth Godin we'll link up a couple other
resources as well as the vid IQ
um thing but let me pass it back to you
final thoughts on Ellen's Channel
I think she's made fantastic progress in
the six months that she's been on
YouTube
she has an outstanding outlier video and
whatever it is to do with video length
or
um just the uh broad appeal of that
video or even as you say Sean the weird
aspects of it is the not not the solo
female traveler being weird but like
living in a in an RV with three cats is
that is that the weird aspect of it I
think that is your outstanding video and
I think you should maybe make a second
part on that you could probably make
another video
based off of that video just from the
comments alone because I think it was
about 200 comments if I'm right yet it's
there's tons of valuable information in
those comments
maybe is a q a a frequent last questions
of a Solo Traveler with three cats in an
RV
um but yeah well done to this Creator I
would just think about maybe some
thumbnail tactics to try and improve
going forward yes amazing all right
um Rob uh I'm asking you publicly you
have time for one more I have time for
one more let's do it
all right so the carriage house
thank you for video visiting the
Carriage House a channel centered around
we don't know
um homeschooling Mama four in a little
farmhouse in the Northern Plains of Iowa
here's the email address for business
address it's cool it's multiple places
I hope that's not the login email
address for your YouTube account but hey
we're all learning um and it probably
isn't 2.2 million views we're crushing
we got 25 000 subscribers 151 uploads
Community tab 21 hours ago hey is that
how everyone's doing how is everybody
doing sending people hugs miss you can't
wait to hang on Friday very nice very
engaged 48 comments
um I like that it looks like
I would say this that I would love from
you in terms of the last three posts and
you clearly are got a strong Community
people are are loving you what I just
want to see here though I want to see
question marks
this is crushing so this is something we
can all learn from Daily Posts we need
to keep posting at least once a day on
the community tub and and I love your
vulnerability I was in the hospital I
had a follow-up appointment I'm getting
better I've been beating myself up I
haven't been able to get out of video
and then a lot of love was shared so I
I'm not suggesting
like this should be changed I am at I am
saying the one opportunity I think you
have here is to throw a question mark
out there because it looks like these
are a lot of updates about you which is
cool it is a community tab it's for all
of the above but like you know what
would you like to see next a couple
polls because you especially in your
situation
you're going to get some good feedback
you're going to get some good insights I
just batch recorded
seven eight deep dive Evergreen type
think media podcast they were 100 in
response to
I think media podcast Community tab post
that I got torn apart on because it was
so poorly written Rob I
hey well I didn't get torn apart I got
one negative comment but of course the
way we treat negative comments is is we
take them so personally
um that I'm like I got torn apart
everybody actually just responded to the
question except for person who's like
how about you check your grammar and I
was like all right but listen how I
wrote this
what is your biggest challenge right
what topics would for us to cover in
future thinking of podcast episodes
that's reading it exactly how I wrote it
what topics would for us to cover in
future so it was horrible I was like I
think he was just channeling Yoda but
you like you're a day early you know
it's metaphor of tomorrow but oh what
topics would for us you like cover for
channel that's a good point I should
have said that I would I should have
been like I'm Yoda you're not even on my
level so anyways here's the point though
number one this is embarrassing number
two I I came back to it I was like was I
you know anyways um and then you got but
then I got some good feedback so it was
out of these that I began
the brainstorming and the development of
upcoming videos you have that big
opportunity here and we all do but of
course depending on the size of your
Channel I want to encourage you to lean
in and ask your community what do they
want next the better you can understand
what they're going through pain points
Etc helpful all right Rob's gonna break
down his thoughts here in just a second
but we've had as much as 137 000 views
on a cozy Christmas decorate with me
we have cozy fall kitchen here we've got
a lot of different great videos and
clearly you've had a lot of success
already so Rob how could we maybe take
things even to the next level I am very
encouraged by just the Cadence of the
channel and the views I mean look at
that a Channel of 25 000 subscribers
and Uber consistency in the views it's
between eight to twelve thousand views
per video on the last eight videos that
we can see here and that must suggest it
is a very strong uh returning viewers uh
you've probably got a high average views
per viewer when you post a video
and a
previous viewer sees that thumbnail
they're likely to click on it again so
great stuff there
thumbnails I'm trying to decide whether
I
um like them or they need some
improvement I saw on some of the most
popular ones that again they were using
some barely legible text at the same
time it kind of fits the the vibe of the
Channel with this kind of cozy homely
feel to it
um there are some Channel some genres
where this kind of works particularly in
Beauty I know um certainly in dollar
Hall channels they have these Montage
thumbnails with text that's difficult to
read but it kind of fits the the
approach that the creator has so you
know I don't if they necessarily need to
change that so I'm kind of just raising
a lot of questions in my head Sean
Without Really addressing any sort of
opportunities for improvement so uh yeah
if you want to bring the channel up
again but if you have any um points to
add as well I'd love to hear them but I
wanted to uh go a little bit really
strong I wanted to go a little bit
deeper on um on the thumbnails a lot of
them feel slightly
muted in your photography and I think
just a very
basic update could be a brightness
contrast so I took your your thumbnail
I'm just putting it here into canva and
I'm just I'm up 31 percent
on the brightness of this thumbnail I'm
going to put contrast up I'm actually
going to reduce contrast down and this
is a digital image that's not you know
the original grab or whatever maybe even
up saturation and just using canva and
in my opinion
what I would also want to do here is
perhaps crush the blacks and I'm not the
greatest canva user I'm more of a
Photoshop person but what I'm ultimately
let me even see what Auto enhance gives
me
um and the what I am trying to uh get
across here is that that might seem
subtle but the point to make is that
some of these
I really like even how even this one
could be a little it could pop a little
bit more it could have a little bit more
of a glow to it a little bit more of a
pop to it but when you go in here it
seems a little dark and that you might
say well and even this one this one's
actually backlit I want the cookies to
be glowing yeah and rather than to kind
of just not be so so the skill sets to
lean into
would be
a little would be perhaps photography
and you may need to go DSLR man that's
it's funny to think that that's dating
me but mirrorless camera but like proper
you know uh camera smartphones are
getting pretty good if it's smartphone
then understanding lighting
um but then also post production your
white cabinets and everything else like
you edit the photo right you want it to
to Glow just pop just and and it has the
potential to do that on the other side
of two skill sets photography and photo
editing and then sometimes it might seem
like you're getting a screen grab from
maybe the video so even your newer ones
uh there's definitely something
happening here where it just doesn't
quite have that pop
and for how much skill how many skills
you've developed that is just waiting
for you on the other side of of making
some tweaks
um to that perhaps maybe getting a soft
box again I see your the kitchen is
obviously going to be consistent for you
and so you got this this this uh window
behind you so what is the lighting in
front of you if we take this
conversation just briefly to a whole
other level
for the content creator of your status
and all of us but for your status
anyone who's taking content serious and
is thinking about doing this over the
long haul it is relevant to consider
upgrading
your house
or areas of your house
to support your content creation the
co-author of YouTube Secrets Benji
Travis is a full-time vlogger with him
and his wife Judy
they thought about the lighting across
their whole house because they film in
their whole house but this could be as
simple as
getting higher wattage bulbs in your
kitchen lights
that could be as simple as that because
you're like I'm filming in my kitchen
all the time I'm mainly using my kitchen
lights it could be as simple as getting
higher wattage bulbs or higher lumens
brightness bulbs in your kitchen
that also have adjustable color
temperature
we're going on this is too deep uh and
you could then go depending on the time
of day to match the color temperature of
your kitchen bulbs
that's more Amber kind of a night color
or more of a daylight color so that your
whole kitchen just comes alive in
brightness so to the tune of I don't
know how many can lights you potentially
have in there but to the tune of like
four new light bulbs you could kind of
change the Dynamics of the place you're
consistently filming
going a little bit deeper you could say
well one of our goals money's coming in
let's actually install some new lighting
and for all of us watching just consider
that how you can apply that to yourself
over time you know you're it's never
about your resources it is about your
resourcefulness using what you have
today Excellence is doing the best with
what you have today but I would imagine
brand deals are coming your way stuff's
coming in so there's some opportunities
that you have to
uh to do all the above and then the
final thing is the reason I say
mirrorless camera is a mirrorless camera
can take bad lighting situations or less
light or whatever and with the proper
editing all of a sudden it looks like
there was all the light in the world
it's just they're basically cameras that
can perform better in low light so
that is not I don't mean to go too much
on a tangent there because that's not
like the biggest deal but it certainly
is going to help I know rob you
mentioned a little bit more about fonts
things like that let's land the plane
officially on a little bit of the video
okay
now
[Music]
videos
hello it's Becca and welcome to a gentle
morning here at our little farmhouse on
the Northern Plains of Iowa the
weather's been so beautiful and
refreshing flowers are in bloom and the
Earth is spoken without sound Birds
seeing not because it has an answer but
because it has a song
this is amazing like I'm laughing
because it's so amazing like the but
because the Earth is smoke spoken not
because of
and uh what's also interesting is I I've
got to lean into the style the style is
different than what we would typically
um talk about but but it is amazing like
it and your audience I think is coming
for this plus you have promised calming
slow living and homemaking and this
would be the opposite of the Mr
beastification of YouTube
and I love that and I think there's a
big opportunity you know for that and so
uh yeah
when we were 20 seconds into the intro I
was thinking this is uh
not going fast enough for me and then as
soon as we got into the uh the voice
over
and more car you know like the candles
being lit and these uh affirmations I
thought to myself you know what this
video isn't for me but that's perfect
because it is for Their audience and
Their audience loves this content the
the production quality is off the scale
you would see this on like a uh I I
don't know what one of us a cooking
channel on a Sunday morning
it's just fantastic
uh yeah I think one of the reasons why
viewers come back to watch their content
is because
it's very difficult to replicate the
standard and the quality here and so
yeah I guess now we go back to the
um the gateway to the video even more
the thumbnail the thumbnail should be
setting the
the standard is set in a video whereas
it should be that the stand is set in a
thumbnail so whether you want to uh like
Outsource it you know hire like a
professional thumbnail Creator to just
make two or three thumbnails to really
make them pop and then you've got the
design and a template to continue making
it yourself uh yeah like Sensational
content incredible
yes um all right and uh one of the
questions came in is uh the carriage
house this channel recommended or asked
do you recommend listing your latest
video as a channel trailer to
potentially get more views what would
your recommendation be for her as well
as others about what video to use for
channel trailer should you use Channel
trailer Rob so unless you're really good
at what a channel trailer is is which is
to introduce your channel within us
within 45 seconds which I think is
really difficult to do and I abandoned
this idea several years ago I take the
video that best represents my channel
and has a very high conversion of
subscribers
that's typically what I do if I don't
want to make a channel trailer
specifically
you may want to create a different
Channel trailer for those who are
already subscribed if you're trying to
get say call to action out of it be it
signing up to an email list or buying a
product or service
that's my general advice Sean but I
haven't really thought about Channel
trailers for a good long time so I'd be
fascinating to know if you have a
counter suggestion to that
yeah no I think we I think they're cool
if you have one we do not we we launched
the think media podcast with one what's
back when it was called the think
marketing podcast so it's we no longer
use that and we haven't changed it since
we do typically just we just look in our
library of the video that is
um most likely to convert subscribers
uh or that has been good at consistently
converting subscribers or essentially
that has a level of satisfaction and
then you just figure like what is a good
first impression for you so I think
that's a good way to go it's a quick way
to solve it
um uh lastly and I want to let Rob go
but I do want to illustrate here
um what I was talking about photography
earlier I do think that perhaps my
points were clear but what I just did
was look up
a a farmhouse
um type
photography and I found this blog post
so
a couple things that this individual is
doing
is to the left of this photo is
the window and in your video I could
also see that certain scenes are lit in
a certain way because of the light
source and the angle of the light so
this is a pretty good photo and it has
that more Airy look to it as does this
Photograph photo with the window over to
the left again and then
um back to this shot
similarly as well it has that Airy and
it's kind of an Overexposed look I'm not
trying to influence your style any in
any way I am just suggesting that I
think we could all learn about this
stuff in regards to best practice the
level of ads on this level it's so funny
has Sean been shopping on Express is
Express retargeting me right now
um so in some cases though this is It's
a photography thing it's also a light
thing it's also how do you fake light uh
we recently got
um I wonder Victoria if you could find
me a link to uh a the lights that Kyle
bought
um but it's a tube light
and
these my friends could revolutionize
your and you'd want uh what bi-color
maybe
and that means that it could be multiple
different colors and for video
so
it's a light that we can carry around
and put in odd places that can really
kind of uh
you don't necessarily need RGB and in
this case I this isn't really the style
of the channel I wouldn't think but
would you take a light like this and you
could then
um you could maybe find ways to mount it
again softboxes work but what I'm after
is even this idea like you start
thinking that these types of Lights
could simulate window lights at
different places in the kitchen and
really change those different shots and
that's just just a caveat so
um with that
I have a few questions that came in but
I'm gonna let Rob go so Rob if you want
to check you out people want to follow
you I'll be on for just another about 10
minutes to answer some of the four
question marks that came in if you got
any final questions always four question
marks before and after but Rob if people
want to connect with you follow you
where are you at
if you search for vid IQ then you are
very likely to find me
um I decided a while ago that in terms
of representing myself on social media
it would be all through vid IQ because
once I finish work for them today I just
want to put aside the internet social
media and everything but
while I'm in my work hours vidi key will
find me there in a YouTube Community tab
on Twitter Instagram do a check me out
and Sean I'm more than happy to stay on
and answer a few questions uh up until
the top of the hour I'm free but there
is something I do want to watch at nine
o'clock so that it is quite late here
but yeah I can stay around for a bit
longer if you want me to then please yes
I just wanted to make sure we uh I asked
for that earlier
and here we go is the AI title generator
in the phone app and this is being
referred to the vid IQ AI title
generator I think it is but I'm gonna
check right now while that question has
been us all right we'll be back so if if
we have a high performing video how do
we analyze it what analytics should we
consider I think that'll be a fun
question for uh Rob but the list would
just be check out your audience
retention curve what are the positive
things you can learn from it what are
the negative things the hold is there
any like if it holds attention audience
retention curve
if there's any significant dips what can
we learn from those is there a point in
the video where it drops significantly
what happened at that point of the video
is there a point in the video where it
was it goes up what does that mean it
means people rewound one of the biggest
insights or one of the biggest
opportunities is to study perform any
video that people rewind it creates a
pyramid they re-watch it they re-watch
that part that part could be a short
that part could be
a new video like what you talked about
there someone's so interested in it or
that part was interesting it tells you
when you should cut Clips out or when
shorts could be there or it just might
provide an Insight like oh people found
this was interesting I should weave this
in at other uh in future content as well
but Rob what'd we learn about that
anyway see if my uh yes there's a zoom
so if you go to the optimize section of
the mobile app and type on a video
then you can get title recommendations
right here
on the mobile
and again today's stream was brought to
you by vidiq.com forward slash think if
you want to do a 30-day trial of bit
iq's paid plan for just one dollar head
to vidiq.com forward slash think where
you can get the AI title generator and a
lot of other cool tools to help you get
more views optimize your channel make
better data driven decisions link is in
the description down below so check that
out
um I'm eligible for monetization tonight
congratulations
should I immediately turn it on or is
there a reason to wait I've seen Eaves I
believe that means Daryl Eaves say wait
but I've never heard why
well first of all I don't know if his
sound effects is going to work but
my light should turn green to indicate
you've reached monetization
congratulations
um I never want to
um disagree with anything Daryl Eve says
about turning on monetization about
whether to turn on monetization or not I
would certainly start experimenting with
one or two videos to get an
understanding of how monetization works
for your channel and how much revenue
you could potentially earn from those
videos but I think the broader question
is Sean cool you've got monetized but
have you been sitting on your hands
waiting to get monetized when what you
should also be doing is thinking about
other income revenue streams be it
sponsorships brand deals reaching out to
companies who you think would work well
with your audience selling courses
products Digital Services
ultimately for most channels ad Revenue
represents a small percentage of a whole
income Revenue pie so to try and not
disagree with Daryl completely I would
say select two or three videos turn on
monetization just to get an idea of how
much CPM you're likely to earn on your
videos how it impacts your viewers
um attitude to your content because they
may be seeing adverts for the first time
on your content so it might be
interesting to see how they react yeah
my guess is uh guessing what Daryl meant
and I think I think this might be what
it is is there's sometimes a good
common recommended advice of you should
hold off monetizing your audience right
meaning you should build trust you
should
build Goodwill you should be patient you
should you know add more value really at
the end of the day money too right is in
exchange for value our income is
directly correlated to the amount of
value we add to the marketplace whereas
in some people people might be like you
haven't added value yet all I met you
and it's like you tried to sell me a car
so that would be what not to do
I think and agreeing with Rob Daryl's a
Legend
um and very smart but my thoughts
specific specifically about YouTube ads
is I don't think people understand the
difference meaning this if you don't pay
for YouTube premium the the culture on
YouTube is ads
and you're going into that it's also
true on Hulu and so whether people like
it or not I don't actually think a lot
of times they think of as is attributed
to the Creator though if you're here
you're watching this let me know if you
think about that you're like oh my gosh
I wasn't getting ads on this person's
video now I am because even when you
click on video sometimes it may or may
not be that an ad gets served even if
the channel is monetized and it could be
I know that there could be some times
where longer videos people like Hammer
the Middle with mid-rolls and and maybe
it's like come on man and maybe people
can see that but as a general rule you
turning on monetization
um and then there's the
YouTube conspiracy theory
that no if if you don't turn on ads it
doesn't affect whether your video gets
promoted or not and we believe that's
true however
what does YouTube ultimately want how
are they even going to stay in business
we made a video about that exact topic
um because you know ironically enough I
forget this we didn't turn on
monetization on the vid IQ Channel until
last year so we we've been offering
content ad free for five years and you
know you raise a good point Sean about
uh building trust with your audience so
when we first turned on monetization we
kept a really close eye on if it
impacted views and Views actually went
down
slightly over the first 30 days that we
monetized our videos so I think it's a
conspiracy theory but since then in the
last year our views have gone up about
50 to 100 so who knows maybe it does
have an impact you didn't hear it here
though I'm not going to confirm or deny
that Andrea says can you change settings
and monetization after you can you can
turn it on and off you can change the
different ad formats you could do a live
and turn it on for the replay but you
can also turn it on before you go live
so that they're running as soon as live
viewers are joining as well so
um okay
uh
how can wholehearted Huli thanks for
being here and thanks for being a part
of era really appreciate you how can I
stand out in a crowded niche of
productivity and personal development
I'll give you my take and then uh Rob
I'm curious any thoughts
um Zig Ziglar says it's better to be
a meaningful specific you don't want to
be a wandering generality
I think that one of the best when I
think about something like personal
development I like to think about
something
specific
for example
running
and if there's a running Channel
You could argue that's a personal
development Channel
because it's going it's with mindset and
you could also argue that well having to
be a runner albeit hobbyist there's
books on running documentaries on
running there's whole cultures Around It
Rich Roll the whole thing there's shoes
on running there's whole and by the way
as soon as I plant my flag and say I'm
going to start a running Channel even
with how crowded it is out there in my
opinion the opportunity is just so
endless because you're a meaningful
specific especially too then you Niche
down like
running for Baby Boomers how to run
marathons as a baby boomer running you
know there's there's a track level
there's a hobbyist level there's all
different distinctions we have a video
coming out on the think media podcast so
make sure you're subscribed on 13
different ways to Niche down we think
like there's personal development there
is and then there's 13 distinctions you
could go deeper than that so that's
coming soon but
ultimately I like to think about okay
personal development I love book summary
channels
uh personal development and what I think
sometimes people struggle is
they just maybe start sharing personal
development talking head videos and you
can seem like an echo in doing that so
it's how do you potentially achieve
productivity yes productivity could be
you could get in front of a whiteboard
you could share your screen you could
just deliver tips
but is there a different vehicle
for which to convey productivity or is
there a higher could your Niche how can
you stand up this I guess it's also
telling you how can you stand out
in a crowded niche of productivity don't
Niche around productivity and personal
development only but Niche around a
particular person
a particular demo Niche around helping
men
Gen X helping Millennial men
boost their productivity
strengthen their mindset and div and
grow
so the niche became Millennial men
achieve a certain thing and now you're
not a Wandering generality you're a
meaningful specific Rob
I look at it from this perspective if
you're in a crowded Niche how do you
stand out you could be faster than your
competitors in the commas to the YouTube
Market with your content for example
chat GPT has been revolutionizing
productivity so imagine if you were
releasing the latest videos that nobody
else has yet thought about in terms of
productivity for chat GPT you can be
bigger than anyone else and what I mean
by that is if somebody is going to offer
10 productivity tips well you know what
I'm gonna offer 50 productivity tips in
eight minutes you're not gonna be able
to get that anywhere else it is unique
content to my Channel or
put simply you're better than anyone
else at the content you're delivering
and if you're going to go through that
Avenue of approach I think there's three
things you want to focus on uh to begin
with and get really good at really quick
is your title and your thumbnail which
we have talked about at length during
this live stream and then also the hook
those are the three critical components
to getting viewers in the the door of
your video and then getting to sit down
in your YouTube theater in the first 10
seconds with that hook
final question smash like if you can get
value today and share uh any aha moments
in our culture we are hashtag action
takers and we're not just here for
information so uh we want transformation
we want to apply what we're learning so
any insights and anything that you're
going to do update on your channel
anything that you want to apply to your
next video anything you want to apply to
your next
title or thumbnail uh the final question
is back on the Carriage House what about
end screens I typically do 10 seconds
branding ending with my videos any
thoughts on how to make an engaging
ending or keep my audience from dropping
off and here is an example of that video
we will watch
we're ending on the cat
the birds
the candle
the candle's blown out
and now thanks for watching with link
somewhere else a channel and one video
10 seconds Landing ending the plan and
just to be clear I'm not sure if that's
what she's saying she always does so
let's check it out
and if you have any thoughts about how
it should be used
or how this could be different
um so it looks as if it's quite an
extensive musical Montage to lead out
the video I think that could be an
indicators of a view that the video is
finished especially putting thanks for
watching that is a trigger for somebody
leaving the video also
what I do personally is I give the
viewers just one link so not even a
subscribe button just a link to the
video that I intentionally want them to
watch
and the only way I'm gonna do that is if
I tell them
what they should watch and what they're
going to get out of it so it might
require a bit of a last 20 seconds voice
over and again try not to say thanks for
watching this video I hope you enjoyed
this video something more along the
lines of so now you really relaxed we
sat in front of a sofa drinking some hot
coffee with a roaring fire you're
getting a little sleepy and this is the
next video you need to watch to finally
send you to the land of counting sheep I
just made it up in my head right now I
hope that's gonna make you click on the
video
I love it
um and uh Rob has a show to watch in two
minutes and so I want to shout out some
of the AHA moments though and uh the AHA
thank you for being here but I will
Niche down Niche and down niche
Rob's up in Canada internationally we
know it's pronounced Niche here in
America you say Niche Niche I sometimes
say
um more Community post aha moment uh
Victoria on think media team hit like if
you found today's stream helpful that
would be helpful appreciate you whole
wholehearted Huli thank you really
appreciate you grateful for you
um aha
moments are coming in and so thank you
for sharing those we are hashtag
actiontakers The Carriage House really
appreciates you grateful for you uh aha
moment switch from tubebuddy to vid IQ
you heard it here I couldn't possibly
comment on such an action but
but we can head nod and uh
and uh thank you again y'all thank you
Rob appreciate you check out the vid IQ
Channel check out a summary of links we
did have two book recommendations today
some good ones those should be in the
description uh you can get the one
dollar vid IQ opportunity uh that is
available in the description too or in
the comments and I want to thank you so
much for being here my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel this
is the think media podcast smash like if
you got value and I will see you in
another video peace